usa el método de completar el cuadrado
para encontrar el valor de ese que
convierte la expresión x cuadrada menos
44 x cm en un trinomio cuadrado perfecto
después describe la expresión como un
binomio al cuadrado lo primero que
quiero hacer es escribir otra vez esta
expresión aquí abajo para que no se me
olvide y vea qué es lo que tengo que
hacer
x cuadrada menos 44 x más cm y esto
tiene que ser un trinomio cuadrado
perfecto y recuerdan que es un trinomio
cuadrado perfecto pues es aquel que se
puede factorizar en un binomio al
cuadrado perfecto y como se ve un
binomio cuadrado perfecto
supongamos x + a al cuadrado que al
final pues es lo mismo que masa por x
masa y bueno pues vamos a multiplicar
cuántos x + a por x + x por x x cuadrado
x por am a x a por x pues también esa x
idiap ahora me queda a cuadrada y esto
se puede reducir un poco esto es lo
mismo que es cuadrada más dos veces a x
aquí hay una equis y aquí también hay
una x esto se reducen a dos veces a x
más el cuadrado del segundo es decir el
cuadrado
y entonces este resultado es justo mi
trinomio cuadrado perfecto y si te das
cuenta que la izquierda ya tengo es
cuadrada y después tengo un -44 que
multiplica x lo cual tendrá que ser 2
samb y c por lo tanto tendría que ser
igual a cuadrada a ver vamos a
escribirlo -44 es lo que está al lado de
la x es decir si quisiéramos que fuera
un trinomio cuadrado perfecto menos 44
tendría que ser igual a 2a y entonces se
tiene que ser a cuadrado es el término
que no tiene que ver con x que es igual
a cuadrado muy bien y como sé cuánto
vale an pues yo tengo que menos 44 es
igualdad 2 am qué les parece si divido
todo entre 2 esto entre 2 y esto entre 2
2 entre 2 se van y entonces me queda que
menos 22 es igual a o dicho de otra
manera a es igual a menos 22 y perfecto
ya tengo el valor de amd si a vale menos
22 entonces menos 44 x es dos veces el
primero pues segundo y por lo tanto esto
se empieza a aparecer cada vez más a un
binomio al cuadrado perfecto ahora lo
que me falta saber es cuánto vale se o
dicho de otra manera cuántos el cuadrado
se es igual a cuadrada que es lo mismo
que menos 22 al cuadrado y cuantos menos
22 x menos 22 haber 22 por 22 bueno al
final recuerden que menos por menos me
da más por lo tanto no es necesario
poner el signo 2 por 2 son 4 2 por 2 son
4 y después como un 0 2 por 2 son 4 2
por 2 son 4 y me queda 4 8 4 484 el
cuadrado de menos 22 es lo mismo que 484
por lo tanto si quisiera que esta
expresión fuera un trinomio cuadrado
perfecto se tendría que ver así x
cuadrada menos 44 x + 484 y entonces ya
lo podríamos factorizar en un binomio al
cuadrado perfecto porque esto es x
cuadrada menos dos veces el primero por
el segundo es más déjenme ponerlo si x
elevada al cuadrado más dos veces el
segundo que es menos 22 por x más el
cuadrado del segundo es decir el
cuadrado de menos 22 y como está pasando
esto ya lo puedo escribir como un número
cuadrado perfecto porque usando lo que
está escrito a la derecha
esto me queda como x menos 22 que
multiplica a x menos 22 o dicho de otra
manera esto
x 22 elevado al cuadrado todas estas son
expresiones equivalentes